my name is Jacob Schreiber and I'm here
to talk with you about pomegranate which
has been a it's been a side projects
last obsession of mine for the last few
years so I'm really excited to be able
to talk with you about it it's the first
time I've talked about it at a public
audience ever thank you I mean I think
that applause may be premature maybe you
should like wait to see if I actually
know what I'm talking about
so pomegranate is a fast and flexible
probabilistic modeling language for
public modeling for for Python and there
is an accompanying ipython notebook
which I forgot to tell the I forgot to
tell you organisers about in time but
basically if you go to the main if you
go to the main pomegranate github
repository which is github coms last gem
spice lass
pomegranate like up here then you'll see
a folder called tutorials and in this
folder called tutorials the top one is
going to be the ipython notebook
tutorial that goes along with this talk
in addition there are other tutorials
that correspond to the individual models
which we'll be talking about in case you
want some additional examples code or
anything else so pomegranate to get you
know to do the administrivia at the
beginning it works on all platforms it
works on Python too it works on Python 3
and it has a pretty simple set of
requirements which is just job live
Network acts numpy scythe on MATLAB and
if you want pretty graphical models then
pie graph is all of these except for pie
graph is seemed pip install of all the
last so it should be fairly easy to get
pomegranate really started when I was an
undergraduate at the University of
California Santa Cruz and yes that
really is the logo the mascot is the
banana slug a very ferocious logo I was
working I was doing research in the
nanopore group and I was doing research
in the nanopore group which is basically
trying to develop a new DNA sequencing
technology the premise behind how this
technology worked was that if you move
strands of DNA do a really small hole
called a nano pour the
the different nucleotides so to impede
ionic current in different ways and you
should be able to decode these ionic
current fluctuations in order to get
back the original sequence this should
allow you to be much faster and accurate
than more much faster and accurate than
other technologies which currently exist
in addition a currently available device
called the mini on basically requires
you to just put in small samples of DNA
and you into a thumb drive like thing
that you literally plug into your
computer in contrast all other
technologies are the basically these big
box servers that around the size of a
big moving box so it's pretty crazy an
example of the type of signal that you
would get from the nanopore looks
basically like this you can see that
there seem to be these distinct ionic
current segments and each one of these
segments does correspond to a different
nucleotide going through the pore it
seems pretty easy that if you use some
sort of model you'd be able to take in
these ionic current segments and decode
it back into the original sequence
unfortunately the group at the time was
made up predominantly of biochemists and
biophysicist because in order to get
this technology working at all you need
a massive amount of domain knowledge
when I started I was pretty much the
first person who had any type of
computer science or statistics
background and so over the course of the
next two and a half years in addition to
publishing papers on nanopore like
things I was able to automate this
entire process a major problem they were
facing at the time is that I made upon
that they were facing at the time is
that they could oftentimes take so it
could take several times longer to
analyze the data than the simply
collected and so they are left with
situations would take them a few days to
collect the data and then a few months
in order to analyze it in addition if
you're doing this by hand you're going
to introduce human biases into the
results and I do remember a lot of times
when we'd be sitting around a table
trying to figure what exactly the result
was and everyone arguing with everyone
else because they all had their own
there are their own metrics so when a
segment ended or what an event really
was and everyone would just argue with
each other it seemed like a mathematic
solution was the most appropriate thing
so my adviser and I first talked with
this problem by finding a way to segment
these into the discreet
Tonks basically different segments are
indicated by different by different
color pattern adjacent segments have
different color or where the boundary
happens then more importantly were able
to take in these segments and feed them
into something and feed them into a
hidden Markov model and these hidden
Markov models act as classifiers in
order to take the sequence and decode it
back into the original biological
sequence in this in this particular
example what we see is that we have
sequences which differ at a single
nucleotide and we want to use the
nanopore in order to identify what the
different modification is at that
position the spike in teal indicates
that at that position the hidden Markov
model has high confidence that we see a
certain one at the modifications called
hydroxymethyl situs in the sharp magenta
tag later on indicates that it made a
correct classification so after
finishing at the university of
california santa cruz i went to become a
graduate student at the university of
washington which has a you know much
more traditional mascot the Husky though
I still personally think that the banana
slug could take it in a fight I was
taking computer science classes
particularly machine learning classes
and one of the things that I found was
that I was basically lamenting the same
algorithm over and over again sometimes
literally in the first year I had to
implement general mixture models three
times for three different classes what I
realized was that if I could take apart
if I could take apart the components of
the hidden Markov models that were
implemented in undergrad then I could
create a wide variety of different
probabilistic models that were that you
know were easy beakers so what happened
is that after the second time I had to
implement general extrema said whatever
I'm done I'm done just implementing this
from scratch so I took apart the package
which is originally called yet another
hidden Markov model which in retrospect
is a terrible name and I put all these
components together in pomegranate and
so you allow two you can take the same
probability distributions that you use
to create hidden Markov models and now
create things like mixture models or
Markov chains a naive Bayes or Bayesian
networks after my first year I was
offered an internship at in via papaya
tall working with
scikit-learn team working with the
scikit-learn team as a summer intern the
main tasks that they wanted me to focus
on was to take the gradient boosting
implementation and make it faster during
that summer I learned a huge amount not
just about software engineering but
about getting the bare-bones efficiency
of scythe on and about including
parallel processing in your code this
biography by the way is not just for
your personal enjoyment you're going to
see elements of this occur in like in
how pomegranate is used so ultimately I
contributed a computational trick to
scikit-learn which improve the speed of
the system to you aggressors up to four
times in most cases since this isn't to
you versus often times uses in ensembles
called random forests or using gradient
boosting it ended up speeding up every
algorithm which ended up using decision
tree regressors this was actually not
entirely good because my research team
but my competition research team at
ended up was using decision tree
addresses at the time and I remember
that in a nationwide meeting on the
subject that are studying they notice
that sometime over the summer it seemed
like their algorithm was working a lot
faster and that seemed to help them move
a lot faster than before so not always
great when I returned to the University
of Washington I was supported by the e
Science Institute which supported not
just me but gave me money to develop
pomegranate during the last few was but
really when I was able to focus on
making pomegranate a lot faster and
implement a lot of the features that I'm
going to show you today so there are six
main things that I'd like to talk with
you about like pomegranate seeds they
are basic probability distributions not
the naive Bayes classifier Markov chains
general mixture models hidden Markov
models and bayesian networks however all
of these things still really if you want
to think this metaphor a little bit
further you can say that all of these
things really are still pomegranate
seeds basically all of these things are
still probabilistic models we're
familiar with simple probabilistic model
or something like a normal distribution
or a discrete distribution but a general
mixture model
is still a distribution it is still a
probabilistic distribution albeit a bit
more complicated one a Bayesian network
is still literally a distribution that's
us factored along a graphical structure
because of this pomegranate supports a
great deal of model stacking on the
left-hand side we have a plot of which
models can be stacked within within each
other models the dark blue squares
correspond to Mauro stacking which
currently are supported and the light
blue squares correspond to Mauro
stacking which I'd like to support
sharing we have some obvious results
here first the basic probability
distributions do make up all of the more
complicated distributions like hidden
Markov models and bayesian networks
that's to be expected for people who are
familiar with hidden Markov models they
might be familiar with the idea of AG
mm-hmm which is a general mixture model
hidden Markov model and we can see that
here where general mixture models can be
fit inside hidden Markov models as the
emissions but there's no reason why you
couldn't do something like create a
mixture of hidden Markov models because
the hidden Markov model it says they
structure distribution over a set of
sequences and a mixture is just takes in
a soup of distributions and basically
mixes them together there's no reason
why you couldn't combine those there's
no reason why you couldn't have a
Bayesian network naive Bayes we're all
familiar with these most of us are
familiar with Gaussian naive Bayes we're
trying to compare multivariate gaussians
to each other but there's no reason why
you couldn't compare a Bayesian network
to another Bayesian network in a
classifier there's no reason why you
couldn't compare a Bayesian network to a
multivariate Gaussian and see which one
better fit to the data
soon I would like to support mixtures of
bayesian networks and hidden Markov
models of bayesian networks just in case
you want some more structure inside your
structure on the right hand side we have
models we have this model stacking
compared to other packages that I'm
aware of the orange squares correspond
to other packages which implement
similar features but not to the extent
that pomegranate does in red we have we
have ways of stacking models that to my
knowledge no other Python package allows
you to do so for example I know that say
hmm learn is able to
with using hmm learn you're able to
implement Gaussian mixture model hidden
Markov models but as you'll see in
pomegranate you can implement general
mixture models of arbitrary
distributions they don't have to be
multivariate gaussians so if you leave
this talk knowing nothing else I want
you to know this pomegranate can do more
than other packages it can do it faster
and it's intuitive for you to learn
intuitive for you to use so perhaps
you'll walk out of this knowing two
things first that and second that I'm a
bit you know I'm a bit braggy so when I
was practicing this talk there was one
other point which I really wanted to fit
in here but I couldn't find a way of
natively doing it so I'm just gonna kind
of do it anyway I also want you to know
this multi-threading basically there's
multi-threading not multi processing
because imp and Python frequently you're
limited by the global interpreter lock
so you can't get true parallel you can't
get multi-threading typically you have
to use multi processing but since the
back end of pomegranates implemented in
scythe on almost all of these algorithms
release the global interpreter lock and
you can use multi-threading in order to
get for more efficient parallel
processing than other packages this is
something which I learned doing my
internship with scikit-learn because
they use a similar thing in order to
speed up many of their algorithms so the
overview of this talk is I'm going to
talk very quickly about basic
probability distributions then we're
going to go into the remaining five
models which I mentioned beforehand
lastly what I would like to show you at
the end is how you can train a mixture
of hidden Markov models in parallel
using multi-threading hopefully by the
time we get there you'll be able to see
how intuitive it is to do that and how
you don't need extensive knowledge of
how the back-end behind any of these
things work in order to get complicated
models working it's not quickly about
the API I mentioned that it seems like
everything is basically the same it's
basically a probability distribution and
so it makes sense that they share the
same methods an obvious one is that all
methods implement a log probabilities
last probability that we don't pass on
some data and you'll get and you'll get
the appropriate probability under that
distribution you can sample you can fit
your model system data there are some
other methods
in purple we have the classic cycle in a
pea I these aren't available for all all
methods because basic probability
distributions it wouldn't make sense for
but any model which is composed of basic
probability distributions has this I
could learn like API lastly I want all
models to have a from samples method
currently basic probability
distributions do which I'll get into in
a second but ultimately what I would
like is for you to be able to take a
Bayesian network and do from samples and
have it learn the structure of the
Bayesian network or a hidden Markov
model and learn the structure of the
hidden Markov model these are things
which I really want to get implemented
but I have a million things that I want
to do and I'm pretty much the only core
developer for this package so everything
falls to make of these probably the ones
you use the most or fit and predict
these are the basics I could learn API
are fitting tomorrow or some day to some
data and then using that morrow innate
order to make predictions about future
data you haven't seen yet let's get
started so if you wanted to find a
distribution and you already know the
parameters of the distribution it's
pretty intuitive if you have a normal
distribution you know that the mean is 0
and the standard deviation is to just
feed that it makes sense intuitive if
you have a Gaussian kernel density you
can just feed in the points and that's
fine it does the best feel if you're
unfamiliar with what a kernel density is
it's basically a nonparametric
distribution in this case it takes every
point in flops a little Gaussian
distribution over the point and then the
full distribution is just the summation
of all of these little Gaussian
distributions if instead what you have
data and you want to learn the
parameters of the distribution before
doing anything you just pass it into
using from samples as I mentioned before
I'm not sure how is it can you see this
level of font towards the back now okay
I was worried about this but basically
in the purple box you have normal
distribution dot from samples if you're
following along with the tutorial all of
this code is present in the tutorial so
you can either follow along now or go
back to it later if you're thinking what
the hell is this guy talking about and
then you can just use the public bility
method and you get a normal distribution
that looks like this given data that of
these doc these
that makes sense nothing surprising here
pomegranate supports a wide variety of
distributions we have univariate
distributions kernel densities
multivariate distributions in purple I
have the distributions which I think
that most people will use normal
distributions multivariate gaussians and
discrete but in red I have distributions
that I person look like this is not the
interesting part of pomegranate so I'm
not going to talk about any other
distributions I think we just move on
from now pomegranate can be faster than
all of its competitors in this case
pomegranate could be faster than numpy
at extracting the parameters of
distributions from data let's say that
we have 10 that 1,000 points on the left
that's a typo and 10000 points on the
right pretty much last night I was
desperately trying to get this talk with
Betty and so there might be a few
inconsistencies here but please despair
with me on the left hand side we have
some data which is normally distributed
we can extract the mean and the standard
deviation using the appropriately named
mean and standard deviation method in
dumping alternatively we can just fit a
normal distribution to the data using
the from samples method we can see that
using pomegranate is twice as fast as
not be at extracting these parameters if
you want to extract a multivariate
Gaussian it seems like it's around twice
as fast in order to extract the meat the
vector of means and the full covariance
matrix from the data compared to numb
Faye
one of the reasons that this is so fast
is because pomegranate doesn't go
through multiple times and calculating
the these statistics one at a time it
calculates all of them at the same time
using these concept cards sufficient
statistics basically this is a concept
from Statistics where you can take a
data set and reduce it down to a set of
numbers that you need in order to
perform an exact update for the normal
distribution if you take the sum of the
weight of every point the sum of the
weighted points and then the sum of the
weighted points squared you have enough
information to perform exact updates
without needing to see the data again
this has a great property because it a
summation this means that you can look
at a point a single time add to these
numbers and then move on and never see
that data point again whereas numpy
needed to go through once and calculate
the mean and then again and calculate
the standard deviation
so from these points it's pretty simple
to see how we can get the mean I
actually wrote the inverse here in the
notebook but basically the weighted
points divided by the tail to sum of the
way this makes sense to us but there's
also a way of calculating the variance
using this and that equation is that
equation is there as well by calculating
these sufficient statistics it would be
much faster than packages which do these
things independently and all all of
pomegranates models support this type of
sufficient statistic calculation because
of this pomegranate is natively supports
outer core learning if you're
calculating these sufficient statistics
there's no reason why you have to see
the entire dataset at once this is
through using the summarized and from
summaries method basically we can
compare here two ways of training on
data if we generate five thousand points
we can either fit our distribution
directly to that data or we can chunk it
into five different chunks summarize
each one to the sufficient statistics
and then update the parameters of the
distribution using those sufficient
statistics with the dot from summaries
method the purple looking distribution
here is actually both a red and a blue
distribution corresponding to these two
different methods that are perfectly
superimposed on each other the numbers
which you probably can't read here or
correspond to the parameters that you
learn from each one and to any
noticeable level of precision they're
basically identical so this supports two
main cases the first is when all of your
data can't fit in memory that if your
data can't fit in memory you can load up
chunks summarize it and then when you're
done reading it all use the form
summaries method the second is if you're
doing online learning perhaps you have
an infinite stream of data and you'd
like and you see one of them at a time
or chunks of them at a time you can
summarize the data as it comes in and
then as you want you can update the
parameters of the distribution something
which I'm currently trying to do is I'm
trying to add a third method which is
clear summaries because right now when
you do from summaries you clear the
sufficient statistics that are stored
but if you're doing online learning what
you can want to do is get a as new data
points come in calculate the sufficient
statistics and then update your
parameters but then don't forget what
you saw previously and then over time
you're slowly get better and better
estimates this is a very simple API fix
that I just haven't got it about you but
within the next few weeks we'll be
present in pomegranate so you can so you
can personally decide if you want to
clear your summaries when you update or
if you want to keep them around and
continue to add on to them in the future
pomegranate can be fastened inside pi
sometimes surprisingly so let's take the
simple task of trying to calculate the
probability of a single point under a
normal distribution using saipa usually
you would use normal AAG PDF and you
pass in the point and the mean and the
standard deviation using pomegranate you
just create the distribution object and
do dot log probability if we look at the
time it's around a hundred times faster
to use pomegranate versus scifi in order
to calculate the probability of this
single point and the difference in the
resorting lock probability is negligible
there's a caveat to both of these though
since both numpy and scifi use
vectorized operations for almost
everything that if your data set grows
in size pomegranate is going to do less
well particularly with the log
probability calculation that pomegranate
currently does not have an inner
vectorized way of calculating these
probabilities something which I'd like
to fix soon but if you're calculating it
using a loop using even maybe a thousand
or 10,000 samples
Sify will be faster and so if your goal
is just to calculate log probabilities
under this using a distribution unlike a
million or ten million points you should
use scifi but the internals of
pomegranate frequently require that you
calculate the probability of a single
point at a time and so it's far better
for the internals of pomegranate to have
fast one sock probability calculations
versus having a vectorized form so but
so one of the reasons that this is
faster is because pomegranate
across-the-board uses aggressive caching
in order to prevent be calculating
things that it knows about when you
create a normal distribution object so
before I get to that so first we have
the the PDF of a normal distribution
basically if you have the mean and
standard deviation you plug the sample
that you see into this equation you get
the probability now we can take the log
of this and we can get and this is the
equation to get the log property
but you can see this decomposes into
several terms that don't actually depend
on the data you're calculating the log
probability of and so when you create a
normal distribution object for example
what it does is cast as the value of
minus log square root of 2 pi times
Sigma this means that no matter how many
times you calculate log probability you
are only calculating that value once
likewise
2 Sigma squared can also be cast because
you aren't changing that when you
calculate new log probabilities these
values only need to be updated when you
fit the distribution to new data so what
you ultimately get is basically some
alpha constant minus X minus u mu
squared divided by some other constant
this means that when you're calculating
the probability you don't have to
explicitly take a log or an exponent
which you traditionally do when you
calculate the probability or log
probability onto a normal distribution
this is part of why it's so fast and
pomegranate to make these calculations
so I think that at this point it's been
kind of dense and so I'd like to get to
a concrete real real-world example that
I think that almost all of you can
relate to so a few years ago my
girlfriend wanted me to watch Gossip
Girl with her and this show is basically
about a bunch of angsty New York teens
who run around having relationships with
each other getting into trouble and
basically disappointing their parents in
the background there is this enigmatic
figure known as Gossip Girl
who sends out text message lasts just in
time to stir up trouble to be clear this
is trouble that if any of the two
characters ever bothered talking to each
other and having normal conversation
like a human being the drama would go
away immediately but I suppose for
dramatic effect they don't know how to
have conversations with each other let's
take a look at some of these blasts Oh
before we got the Gossip Girl is
supposed to be one of the main
characters and the idea is basically
that the idea is basically that by the
end of the series they'll reveal who
Gossip Girl actually is at the end of
this segment I'm going to review who
Gossip Girl is so if any of you care
about that spoiler maybe you so take
like a five-minute fake and leave real
quick but I figured no one here really
cared so let's take an example of one of
the first last that you see spot
lonely boy can't believe the love of his
life is returned if only she knew who he
was but everyone knows Savina
and everybody is talking wonder what
Leia ward-off thinks sure they're BFFs
but we always thought there's boyfriend
Nate had a thing for Serena that seems
like a shitty thing to say that anybody
much less send to everybody involved in
like the cast but what really got me
hooked on Gossip Girl
was not you can see the intricate plot
and story line but this blast with which
happened at the end of the first episode
why'd she leave why she returned send me
all the deets and Who am I that's a
secret I'll never tell
the only one so basically at that point
I told my girlfriend I'll continue
watching this show with you if you help
me figure out using math who Gossip Girl
is before they've revealed so we came to
that formal agreement to be clear though
I actually enjoyed it the first few
seasons of Gossip Girl but that's a
secret I'll never tell
so what basically happened is that we
went through all of these blasts and we
encode them in terms of whose agenda
they helped and whose agenda they didn't
help
for example better lock it down with
Nate B clock's ticking we can see that
this seems like it's advantageous to
Nate and it's disadvantageous to Blair
so we put a plus one for Nate and a
minus one for Blair the other characters
aren't involved so we don't care about
them this just in essen be committing a
crime of fashion who doesn't love a
Fivefinger discount especially if it's
the middle one this basically is
revealing two of the main characters for
you know committing theft so it's
clearly not in either of their agendas
so this is a minus one for both of them
a fairly obvious thing that you may want
to do at this point is say okay well we
have a bunch of Plus Ones minus ones and
zeroes so lets us sum them up and the
person who has the most positive things
that probably Gossip Girl unfortunately
this doesn't work well it reviews some
interesting things like particularly
that Blair doesn't seem like she's very
well liked it would it would be very
surprising if there was Gossip Girl
given that she has around twice as many
negative things said about her as the
next person however this doesn't tell
you this doesn't quite tell you who the
person most likely to be Gossip Girl is
because Dan Nate and Vanessa are all
tied at having the
least negative difference between them
so we have to move to probabilistic
modeling in order to get a more nuanced
view of what's going on here at CERN
quickly to the idea of beta
distributions i know that i lured you
into this complicated mathematic topic
with the promise of gossip girl but
we're gonna have to cover this basically
beta distribution distribution between 0
& 1 which are basically which are
usually used as a way of a representing
a probability distribution over the
probability that an event occurs that
may be a bit complicated but the typical
example is if you have a coin and you
want to figure out what is the
probability that this coin is going to
produce heads the blue distribution is
before you've seen anything you've seen
no head and no tails until there's a
uniform distribution you have really no
idea what this coin is going to do
because you haven't seen any data the
tío distribution shows what happens
after you see two tails that if you used
something if used maximum likelihood
estimate you'd say okay well the
probability of seeing heads is zero over
two so it's zero percent and the
probability of seeing tails is two over
two so a hundred percent but this is a
more probabilistic view which says that
while it's most likely that it's
impossible to produce heads there's
still probabilistic density over these
other values what's interesting and good
is that as soon as we see a single head
the red distribution the red disabusing
kind of curves down instead of curving
up it says that there's literally a zero
percent chance that this coin can't
produce heads which makes sense we just
saw a head it would be impossible for
the coin to not be able to produce heads
in fact now the peak of the distribution
seems to be around one-third probability
of producing heads as we get more and
more observations maybe we see that we
have 25 heads in 25k and this
distribution begins to be look like a
normal distribution of allen 0.5 it
continues to act intuitively well if we
saw a thousand heads in a thousand tales
this distribution would have a smaller
variance but still be centered around
0.5 it makes sense so let's do this for
gossip girl basically we have heads and
tails which of whether or not a blast
was in favor of your agenda or against
your agenda and if we look at the first
season we get beta distributions which
look like this with the maximum
likelihood parameters shown in in the
vertical lines
that's interesting is that Blair was so
drastically negative when we just took a
sum but if we have this more
probabilistic view she comes in
basically in the middle it comes in this
as the second highest I guess not the
third highest most like they except for
Vanessa who we haven't seen it all yet
but by the time we get to the end of the
fourth season what we see oh that these
distributions tied in as you get more
evidence one way or another for each one
of these characters ultimately what we
get at the end of season four is that
all these characters are kind of close
together which makes sense because my
understanding of what happened is that
the producers of the show had no idea
who Gossip Girl was going to be and so
at the end of the sodas randomly chose a
character that they thought would work
but didn't actually work though perhaps
there was some perhaps there was some
signals all along because using this
simple probabilistic method we see that
even though it's not by much Dan is most
likely to be Gossip Girl and ultimately
Dan is revealed to be Gossip Girl okay
let's move on so I will admit that
that's probably my most interesting
exact four of the day so let's get to
naive Bayes if you're familiar with
classical machine learning you may say
okay if I have multiple if I have
multiple probability distributions like
the red and the blue one how can I make
a classifier using this how can i how
can in the same way that i have logistic
regressions which will predict future
points how can I use these probability
distributions to do the same thing in
the app basically through something
called Bayes rule and without going into
the details what this really gives you
is the posterior probability the
probability of each model given the data
is equal to the probability of the data
given the model times the prior
distribution to break this down even
more the prior distribution is basically
if I haven't seen any data yet which
model do I think it most likely is if I
have no if I have no belief over there
so I don't know anything this can just
be a uniform fire but if I have a
process which generates positive
examples that evade ten times more
likely than negative examples we can
encode that it's ten times more likely
that you see a positive example than a
negative example using this prior you
likelihood function is the simple thing
that we were talking
before we just calculate the probability
or log probability of the data given the
model so this is the it's a simple log
probability calculations the posterior
is the probability of the model given
the data which is the real thing that
you're after when you're trying to when
you're trying to make a prediction so
naive Bayes supports a predict method
with what you can see here is that if we
take points on a grid the the dots then
at a certain point they stop being blue
and they stop and they start being red
what this corresponds to is basically
the odd max of the model over the
posterior probability basically it's the
model that's most like that is most
probable given the data if you don't
fully understand this that's fine
at this point it's we're not gonna go
too deep into it but in a dist predict
method that like scikit-learn has we can
go a little bit deeper and look at this
more probabilistic thing instead of
having a hard call that says this is
component 0 or this component 1 what we
can say is what is the posterior
probability that its component 1 in this
case component 1 is the red distribution
and what we see is the posterior
probability plotted for points that are
clearly under the red distribution or
clearly under the blue distribution we
can see that the difference between the
predict method and the predict farber
method is trivial it's basically the
same thing but what's interesting is
that as we approach the boundary where
the blue density and the red density
seem to be the same that we get more
likely that were less about are will
less so about our prediction this can be
incredibly useful because it allows you
to identify boundary cases and perhaps
if you're in industry and you're working
on a simple classifier then what you're
saying is that if the posterior
probability is above you know 0.99 we're
so event but if the posterior
probability is between 0.4 and 0.6 or
something we really have no idea and we
need to look at these examples more
carefully I oftentimes say that this
type of probability calculation
basically allows you to carry your
uncertainty around with you much like a
graduate student so there are two main
ways that you can create naive Bayes the
first is that you can explicitly create
distributions in the same way
you were doing them before and then
passing a list if you want to have fires
you can pass in a list of that as well
but that's not important right now
the second is that if you want to use a
psychic learn like method will you
create a naivebayes that is unfit and
then you fit it to data later on you can
simply pass in a constructor for the
distribution that you care about in this
case we're taking naive Bayes and we're
passing in normal distribution this
means that when we fit this model to
data later on we will will basically
partition the data set into each label
and fit normal distributions to this
without you having to pass in initial
estimates for any of them naive Bayes
can be a lot faster than scikit-learn
here we're just looking at a simple
normal distribution on one dimensional
data it would be a bit unfair to compare
pomegranates multivariate Gaussian
distant dimensional one because not
scikit-learn does not learn the full
covariance matrix of your of your
multivariate Gaussian distributions it
only learns the diagonal pomegranate
learns the full covariance matrix and in
many practical applications learning the
full covariance matrix is not only
useful it's necessary however what we
can see here is that in this example we
are increasing the number of samples per
component there are two components so
basically the total number of samples is
I'm sterile and we can see I've an a
comparison between the two five times
I'm plotting the mean as the line and
the men in the max as the as the colored
area on the y axis we have the number of
times faster than pomegranate is when I
first learned this plot I thought I was
being a little bit cocky because if the
numbers come in under one that means
that I could learn is actually faster
but fortunately for me it seemed as
though it was the right thing to do what
we see here is basically that if we have
a small number of samples that
pomegranate can start off being around
11 times faster than scikit-learn if
making predictions as we increase the
number of samples this seems that
converges to being around twice as fast
as I could learn at making predictions
likewise with fitting this fitting the
naive Bayes we start off being around
four times faster and we seem to
converge to being around twice as fast
as I could learn on the bottom we have
accuracy plots basically we're making
predictions about the data that we just
I think it's the data that we just fit
on and just to see whether or not we
were getting the same results between
pomegranate and scikit-learn we're
getting a basically purple plot here
which is showing that we're getting
exactly the same result between
pomegranate and scikit-learn
so the increase in speed isn't because
I'm making approximation or not learning
the fourth thing it's just because naive
Bayes is faster I also talked about the
out of API that pomegranates support
scikit-learn also supports an out of
korah
API for some of its methods using the
partial fit method so I wanted to
compare not just the speed in doing this
but what exactly was going on because
when you cut every time you call parcel
fit using the using scikit-learn you get
a fully fit estimator
whereas in pomegranate you have to call
from summaries in order to update from
summaries so it's not exactly the same
however it seems as though pomegranates
are tough around four times faster and
ends up being around twice as faster
that's diminishing and it's producing
basically the same classifier as socket
learners so let's get to a less
interesting example than Gossip Girl
basically that's imagine that you have
some facets which is generating noisy
signals there are two underlying bazooms
and when you're in one of the regimes
you produce data that's distributed
normally with some standard deviation
and some duration we can see here that I
have some examples colored either blue
or red to represent the two regime the
the two labels that the underlying
regime we can take one of these segments
though and we can reduce it down to the
mean the standard deviation and the
innovation these would be three
important characteristics to add to your
model we can say that means are usually
normally distributed and so we'd like to
use a normal distribution in order to
model them we could say that standard
deviations are usually gamma or log
normally distributed so let's use a log
normal distribution to model that and
lastly de basins are almost always
exponentially distributed so we'd like
to fit an exponential distribution to
that if we were to use scikit-learn we
would only be able to let you will only
be able to learn multivariate Gaussian
naive Bayes whereas we know that these
other dis
yusin's are more appropriate for the
different dimensions so what we do in
pomegranate is fairly intuitive we
simply define the underlying
distributions that we that we'd like to
use in this case the normal distribution
log normal and the exponential we pass
this into an independent components
distribution which basically says that I
am dealing with a multivariate problem
we from the other basically there's no
covariance matrix to learn then we
passed these independent component
distributions into the naive Bayes in
the same way that we are passing normal
distribution to other distributions in
beforehand we can then fit the model in
the same way that scikit-learn fits
their models except in this case instead
of fitting a Gaussian naive Bayes we're
fitting a naive Bayes that has these
appropriate distributions on each one of
the different columns this can be very
practically useful we see that the ninth
page using normal log normal and
exponential distributions gives you
around an eighty four point six percent
accuracy however if you use down
multivariate Gaussian naive Bayes you
only get 81 point eight percent accuracy
so it seems like simply by choosing the
appropriate distributions tomorrow your
data you're getting a three percent
accuracy again without needing to go in
and collect more features or collect
more data or anything else in this case
I'm comparing the multivariate Gaussian
naive Bayes implemented in pomegranate
to the one implemented in scikit-learn
just give to give baselines basically
it's expected that the to that
pomegranate you saw it's because though
that's basically the same model so I
talked about stacking distributions
let's get to the first example of that
we were talking about Gaussian naive
Bayes or independent naive Bayes or
whatever let's talk about Bayesian
network now you face Bayesian networks
are just distribution with a factor
along a graphical structure like this
one so there's no reason why we couldn't
put that into a naive a structure this
is a typical example of a typical
example of a Bayesian network that talks
about a person's performance in school
basically we see that whether or not you
get a letter of recommendation depends
on the grade you get in a class the
grade that you get in a class depends
both on your intelligence and the
difficulty of the class and the grade
that you get on the SAT depends on your
intelligence
however let's say that we want to detect
cheating with this for a normal person
this may make sense that people who are
more intelligent and take easy classes
or more likely credits but if you're
cheating in the course then there is no
real connection between intelligence
difficulty and grade so let's compare it
to this Bayesian network in this case
what's happening is that we got rid of
these two edges we said that whether or
not you get a letter of recommendation
is still dependent on the grade because
hopefully the teacher may I guess not
hopefully but in this case the teacher
doesn't know if you're cheating or not
the grade that you get on the SAT does
depend on your intelligence because
we're saying you're not cheating on the
SAT you're just cheating in this class
and so we're getting rid of these two
dependencies the way that we are
distinguished between these two is still
using Bayes law the posterior
probability which model is more likely
given this data is still equal to the
likelihood times the fire if we know
that 99% of students aren't cheating
then we'll be able to put a prior
distribution on or naive Bayes saying
it's most likely the person isn't
cheating but Bayesian networks can still
give you likelihoods of data under Lam
so there's no reason we couldn't plug
that into the likelihood function here
so the exact code for creating this is
basically you create a Bayesian network
then you create another Bayesian network
and then you feed them into the naive
Bayes here the two Bayesian networks Rd
and in DC if you want the exact code for
how to do this you can see this either
in that you can see this in the tutorial
later on basically but we can we can use
exactly the same methods that we would
use beforehand with this if we want to
predict the probability you're gonna
predict the probability of some data we
see some intuitive results basically the
numbers here correspond to just like
reading words you start at the top and
you go right and you go down you go
right so the first column is
intelligence and then difficulty SAT
grade then letter the bottom two so the
most extreme examples are being most
likely under these various distributions
and it makes sense that if you're an
intelligent person taking an easy class
and you did well on the SAT but you did
not get a good grade in the class then
it's very likely one cheater like why
would a smart person cheat and this is
meant to be a rhetorical question
like a vo question that you should
answer the most extreme opposite example
is someone who is not intelligent taking
a difficult class who did not do well on
the SAT but still managed to get a good
grade in the class and then ultimately
did not get a letter of recommendation
letter of recommendation doesn't
actually matter in this case this is
basically a simple example of a network
I've implemented here a binary network
but pomegranite supports multinomial
networks basically you can have an
arbitrary number of distributions at MIT
you can have an arbitrary number of
possible a possible values in each one
of the nodes what I do not currently
support our linear Gaussian networks I'm
planning on supporting those soon those
a high priority but currently I only
support discrete networks you can
imagine a more complicated version of
this would been people as intelligent
and to say standard deviations from the
norm on an IQ test and difficulty of the
class would be far more complicated
grade would be instead of just good
grade and bad grade it would be a whole
variety of different things in fact we
can make this example more complicated
that instead of just looking at a single
class maybe we care about every class
that this person has taken how difficult
every class they took was the grade
they'd gone every class and the letter
that they got and so instead of this
being one edge here it would be one edge
per class that they took you could
encode a person's whole academic history
in a Bayesian network and calculate the
probability that they were cheating
versus simply got lucky or unlucky in
the class I don't really want to talk
about Markov chains the very simply
implemented and if you underst - use
them and you understand what's going on
you basically just just feed in and the
Missal just abuse in and then
conditional distributions of increasing
size they're in the tutorial but they're
not very interesting so I'm gonna skip
them for now but they exist
talk about mixture models which I think
are far more interesting let's say that
you have data which looks like this it
seems as though there are two normal
distributions but you don't have labels
for this how are you going to fit a
distribution to this when clearly a
single normal distribution isn't going
to fit and you don't have any labels
this is what mixture models really come
to your aid you can say that I want to
create a mixture model of normal
distributions but specifically to normal
distributions when you fit to the data
it uses an algorithm called the
expectation maximization algorithm in
order to fit these parameters so I could
learn also implements this but the way
that expectation maximization works is
basically you have the chicken and egg
problem if you knew which which normal
distribution generated each sample then
you would just feed all the samples of
that distribution in and do maximum
likelihood estimates you know calculate
the means and deviation of those points
if you knew the parameters the
distribution you could calculate which
with the probability of the point
falling under it but you don't know
either of these things and so the way
the expectation maximization algorithm
works in a nutshell is that you
basically iterate between these two
steps figuring out the probability of a
point falling under that distribution
and then updating the parameters of that
distribution given that assignment until
you reach convergence what you end up
here with here is this bimodal Gaussian
distribution that seam is a flow that
seems to very well model the underlying
mixture that's going on in the same way
that naive Bayes was able to calculate
the posterior probability of the
components mix tomorrow's can do exactly
the same thing in fact doubt mixture
models in naive Bayes are basically the
exact same thing except for how they fit
data naive Bayes fits data in a
supervised manner and mixture models
fits data in an unsupervised manner but
other than that they are literally the
exact same algorithms to calculate the
the to do predict and predict fava in
this case that's calculate the posterior
probability of the two components the
two normal distributions that we just
fit we can see something that makes
sense that basically they clearly fall
in under one distribution or the other
until we get to around the boundary when
it becomes a little bit fuzzier and then
they become more likely to have been in
the other distribution but there's no
reason that we have to stop at normal
distributions
let's take here a mixture of exponential
distributions that I created instead of
passing in normal distribution you can
just pass in exponential distribution
it's a distribution that supports you
just pass that constructor and you say
that you want to have two components of
exponential distributions and you fit it
seems like you get a really good fit if
you fit these two exponential
distributions to that data and if you
quired no additional work on your part
to add things or hack things
gather lastly something that you could
do is instead of passing in a
constructor you can explicitly pass in
the distributions that you want to mix
in this case let's mix an exponential
distribution with the uniform
distribution because maybe what you're
saying is that this this spike at the
beginning was caused by an exponential
distribution but then after this decay
it's equally likely that you generated
from any of these points we can see
after fitting this distribution that
that's a terrible idea
but this is simply saying what
pomegranite supports not what you should
do so you can basically pass in you can
pass in a list of any arbitrary
distribution that you'd like and mix
them together so so Gaussian mixture
models can be faster than scikit-learn
sometimes they can be surprisingly so I
want to say as a caveat that while it
looks like but the two main caveats here
both of these algorithms will want run
two for one iteration of expectation
maximization but they were initialized
differently I didn't go through and have
them in this life the same way and so
that explains why we're getting
different accuracy results in addition
when running speed tests before I have
never seen this number before this
number being quite as fast I've seen it
be twenty times as fast thirty times as
fast but not nearly a hundred times as
fast so I'm right now I'm willing to
talk that up to being some sort of my
laptop was doing something different
when it was supposed to be doing cycle
ends but the consistent message here is
that Gaussian mixed a general mixture
models a way faster in pomegranate than
they are in socket learned that as you
increase to nearly 8000 samples per
component or 16,000 total examples
you're still almost twenty times faster
in pomegranate than you are in
scikit-learn prediction is almost a
steady at being at around 50 10 to 50
times faster meanwhile we seem to be
getting similar results not the exact
same results because these algorithms
are highly dependent on how you
initialize them and we aren't
initializing them in the same way but it
seems like we're getting basically the
same results in pomegranate as in socket
LAN if we instead look at multivariate
Gaussian distribution instead of normal
distributions we say we can see
something similar
basically that pomegranate can be way
faster at fitting these multivariate
Gaussian distributions as his teams like
it's around five times faster you
increase the number of dimensions of the
data pomegranate does seem to have more
variability in the underlying model and
this is a this is something else which I
would like to look into but my
understanding is that basically what
happens is that scikit-learn uses
something called the chilled esky
decomposition which is an approximation
of the underlying out algorithm was
pomegranate learns the exact full
covariance matrix and sometimes in
mixture models given the weights that
you have this can cause very weird
things to happen
so it's something which I'm gonna look
at in the future but it seems like it's
producing something it seems like using
something similar so let's go back to
the noisy signal example that we were
talking about before
basically what we're seeing is that what
we had before is that we had two
underlying components that were
generating these that were generating
these signals previously we required we
required that we had labels on each one
of these segments in order to train our
naive Bayes classifier a more common
example is that we don't have labels and
so we want to be able to do a some sort
of mixture in order to figure out the
two underlying components of this
algorithm this signal we can do it in
pretty much literally the exact same way
that we did naive Bayes we specify these
distributions in exactly the same way
and instead of passing them into naive
Bayes we just pass them into general
mixture model because that's the model
we're passing it into we can see that
using Gaussian mixture models but the
appropriate distributions is giving you
76% accuracy versus be seventy-two
percent accuracy that you would get
using multivariate Gaussian
distributions tomorrow the entire thing
again you're getting an increase of four
percent accuracy just by using the
appropriate distributions in order to
model this stuff like I said at the
beginning these are mixtures of
distributions and a hidden Markov model
is just a structured distribution over
sequences there's no reason why we
couldn't have mixtures of hidden Markov
models so what we do is you basically
have a sub function here which creates a
a hidden Markov model we create two of
these hidden Markov models and we just
pass them into the general mixture model
the graphical model of these it's
basically the same underlying path
with the same edge probabilities but
different emissions for each one of them
basically one of them has a normal
distribution centered around one and
seven and one has a normal distribution
centered on three in ten we can do
normal things that we do with mixture
model here without having to think about
it let's say we generate five samples
from the first hidden Markov model and
ten examples from the second hidden
Markov model if we try to calculate the
posterior probability using predict
prabha what we see are things that are
intuitive the first five points are more
likely to come from the first
distribution the second ten point that
the remaining points are most likely to
have come from the second distribution
except for this one which is kind of an
oddball if you want to fit your
distribution you do it in exactly the
say yeah if you want to fit your mixer
you do the exactly the same way let's
say we generate 100 sequences from the
first sample and a hundred from the
first ten Markham our 100 sequences from
the second one just for just for
expediency what we see is not only that
we get updated changes and probabilities
for the different models but also that
the fire probability is appropriately
learned we learn one third of the
incoming data came from one distribution
and two-thirds came from the other one
and what we're seeing here is that we're
learning that supply of probability of
1/3 chance the first model and firepower
there 2/3 for the second model all of
this is without you having to think at
all about what expectation maximization
is going on especially since both hidden
Markov models and mixture models both
uzm you don't have to think about how
you're gonna stack e/m algorithms within
each other now let's get the hidden
Markov models this is how the puck this
is how the package started and so it's
basically the flagship implementation of
pomegranate the thing I'm most excited
about the most feature be the best
competitive package which I found is a
package called
hmm lon so I created this this chart
which shows things with pomegranate
supports versus things that hmm line
supports I'm not going to go through
each one of these this can be a
veteran's for you to look at later if
you care about it but the most important
thing is that I put shouldn't have done
that the things which I personally care
about the most are silent states a
sports implementation of the underlying
structure having arbitrary disturb you
any of the states tied emissions and
most importantly multi-threaded training
which we're gonna get to at the end
let's take a simple example from
bioinformatics which is the field that
I'm in this is the business idea called
a CPG Island basically if you have
regions of your sequence which are
enriched for CJD nucleotides these are
oftentimes correlated with the function
of the sequence you can find things like
genes promoters and so on
neo CPG CPG rich areas so one of the
first tasks that hidden Markov models
were used for what to try to identify
where these CG my CPG Islands were in
the entire genome for example it would
be kind of silly to go through and say
all c's and g's belong to seedy islands
and all a's and T's don't that would
give you pretty much no information if
you took a voting mean you wouldn't be
able to figure out what the exact edges
of these seedy islands are whereas when
you use the hidden Markov model you're
able to get exact boundaries on these
things through a global up basically a
global dynamic programming algorithm the
way that you create this in pomegranate
is easy you first start off by defining
your two distributions let's say here
that we have a background distribution
where everything is equally likely and
then we have a distribution with CS and
G's or more likely but A's and T's are
still possible because in Sidi Islands
we still see a s and T is to set a lower
frequency then we have this state object
which is present because this is a
graphical model we passed the
distributions in we give them names then
we add the states in and we have and
then one other time we add the
transitions between all of these nodes
to each other this modularity allows you
to build structures allows you to build
structures from the ground up you can
build them within a function slowly
instead of needing to define a big dense
transition matrix at some time which
possibly couldn't even fit in memory so
let's say that we have a sequence here
eivin's I've carefully inserted a single
CD island into the middle of it and we
can see here that the CD Island detector
basically identifies the middle part
well one is here correspond the
background sequence and zeros correspond
the CG Islands we can see that the
basically right at the boundary here
between the G and the T and the C and
the T that's what we call a transitions
we're getting the most optimal CDI
events here
one of the things that I don't
personally like about this that's
calling the end CD Island as well we can
utilize the underlying structure of
hidden Markov models in order to say you
can't end on a CG Island you have to end
on background sequence the way we would
do this is at a single edge to the exit
distribution in this case it says one
more line will be added transition from
the state to the end and here we are
this is what it looks like one of the
other features which I like about
pomegranate is that is that if the edge
is leaving a node don't sum to 1 it will
automatically normalize these edges that
they do something to want sometimes this
may be annoying but it can allow you to
do more more interesting things like
they can all do more interesting things
like basically say that sometimes you
want you want this set of transitions
and sometimes you want the you want
daddy you want to add a single other
just sometimes you want three edges
leaving a node and sometimes you want
four edges leaving the node and all you
have to do is add that single edge in
the if statement as opposed to be
defining your entire structure and
you'll automatically balance it for you
so what you can see here is that by
adding this edge you basically say hey
there can't be a CD Avant at the end and
so when it makes predictions it doesn't
say there's a CG island at the end even
though there's some evidence because you
literally can't get to the end from the
CDA instead if you want to look at this
in a more probabilistic in a more
probabilistic way then we can get the
posterior probability that each element
in the sequence falls under each state
we can see here basically I'm plotting
the posterior probabilities for each of
them and the CD Island seems to have a
high posterior probability for the CD
Island say it in the middle but it seems
like it's a bit iffy on the way even
though a bit iffy but there's it's not a
determinist it is not a hard
classification of one of the actual
probability and this could be fairly
useful hidden Markov models are way
faster than hmm lon there were four main
algorithms which I compared the training
time using the bomb whilst training
algorithm the maximum a posterior
algorithm which is predict father
be Viterbi algorithm which will
calculate the single best path through
the model and the log probability of the
log probability using the forward
algorithm basically the most important
thing here for most people is the
training time and we can see training
this purple line that goes way up if
it's not the one that spikes here but it
stays up here so it seems like with
Lloyds models we're getting to be around
20 times faster at training then hmm
line is oh basically all of these
algorithms are faster but training is
particularly important one of the
reasons that this is the case is because
pomegranate has an underlying sparse
implementation hmm Allah and to my
knowledge
uses the full graph transition matrix
and just multiplies that by itself a
whole bunch of times if you have a
sparse graph most these elements are
gonna be 0 and you're wasting about 2
time pomegranate only stores the edges
that actually exist and so when you
calculate these functions you can get
massive speed-up basically changing it
to be a number of states times number of
ads in the complexity versus number of
states squared let's add a little bit
more structure than this let's say that
we know that there are exactly three CPG
Islands in our sequence we can base this
is gonna be impossible for most of you
but basically what's happening is that
we're saying we can start off in the
background of the CG island and then
after the CD island we go to a
background state eventually then we go
to another CD island defense lay then a
background state then a CGI on that
background and so forth and so we're
saying there are three CG island
somewhere in this sequence but I don't
know exactly well if we take a look at
the predictions then what we're seeing
is that the original model will identify
a single CD island in it whereas if we
look for state prediction 0 1 & 2 we see
0 here 1 here and 2 here this can give
you this can allow you to basically
regularize your predictions
saying that I know that the structure of
the underlying data is like this so I'm
going to explicitly put it in my hidden
Markov model a problem that arises
fairly quickly if you try to do this
type of thing though is that if you try
to fit your model tow to some data
you'll see that the background
distributions and the CD Island
distributions will diverge from each
other here we're looking at two
different CD Islands and after training
they have wildly different distribution
after training the background
distributions have wildly different
distributions and we don't want that
because we're basically modeling the
same phenomena but we just want that
phenomena to happen multiple times in a
very structured manner the way that we
can deal with this is something called
tying distributions together the idea is
that when you tie a distribution
together you say that the when you're
fitting the when you're fitting your
secret is to the data that give me when
you're fitting the model to the data if
the data fits one of the distributions
it fits all of the distributions that it
ties here with the same probability the
way that you can do this is pomegranate
is trivial instead of passing in
different discrete distribution objects
into each one of the states you just
pass the same literally the same
discrete distribution object into
multiple states and now they're tied
with each other to get a practical
feeling for what that actually means if
we try to train our model with these
tied states what we see is that after
training these now have exactly the same
distributions this makes sense because
these are the same underlying phenomena
and so we want the same distribution for
each one of these states
another thing that pomegranate supports
is this idea of silent states the idea
is that you want to have States with
your secret can pass through without
emitting anything basically let's say
that you have this very dense structure
where in each layer of the hidden Markov
model you can connect it everything in
the previous thing I'm not going to Bala
coming up with an example for this
because that's not important
but the idea is that you have a huge
number of edges here and since all of
the algorithms in pomegranate take time
proportional to the number of edges it
would be beneficial in order to reduce
the number of edges in this model what
you can do is add solvent States between
each of the layers if what you were
saying before is that it's possible to
go from any of the states in one of the
layers to any of the states in the
previous layer all you do is you add a
state in the middle and say ok now all
of them can go to this silent state in
the middle and the silence they can go
to all of the others you can
dramatically reduce the number of edges
in your model while maintaining the same
expensive 'ti this reduces it basically
down to N squared and from N squared
edges the to n edges would C be a
massive savings the way that you
implement these silent states that
instead of passing in an explicit
distribution all you do is you pass in
knot that makes sense if there's no
distribution you don't
in anything so now let's talk about
Gaussian mixed mixture model hmm we
talked previously about mixtures of
hidden Markov models but now let's say
that we want our distributions on each
one of the states to instead of being a
single distribution we want it to be a
mixture of distributions we do it in the
exact same way that you would imagine
you want instead of defining your
distribution to be a normal distribution
you define it to be a general mixture
model of distributions and then you pass
that into the state and everything works
exactly the same exactly as you would
imagine it all you do is you pass in the
mixture model as the distribution
instead of a simpler distribution let's
get the Bayesian networks I'm starting
to run out of time so I want to make
sure I get to the finale and have time
for your questions
Bayesian networks are basically a
powerful influence tool which define
these dependency structure between
variables they're especially powerful
because once you define the structure of
a Bayesian network you don't need to
have information about each one of the
variables in order to do influence over
an arbitrary set of the other variables
let's take an example from medical
diagnosis unfortunately not all of us
can be dr. house so let's call this
Bayesian network hut or doctor hut
because it's not quite as good
the spacing network has three main
layers the first layer or genetic
conditions in this case I'm considering
BRCA 2 BRCA 1 and LC T which is involved
in lactose intolerance in the middle I
have three conditions that you may want
to be able to diagnose in this case
ovarian cancer lactose intolerance and
pregnancy in the bottom you have
symptoms that a patient would feel
something like low energy loading loss
of appetite vomiting or abdominal cramps
the edges here represent dependencies
that for example you're more likely to
have low energy if you have ovarian
cancer than if you don't
that makes sense when you are using this
network what you would like to do is
take in symptoms from patient that you
do know about and genetic information
that you do have and be able to do
influence over this middle layer without
needing have all of these you don't want
to be able you don't want to be strained
yourself by saying that in order for
this model to be useful you have to run
the test for
ca2 and brca1 even if it doesn't even
seem like it's gonna be cancer at all
the way this works is slightly different
than the other models that you can pass
in either a list that corresponds to the
that corresponds to each one of these
states or you can pass in a dictionary
we were the keys or the name of the
state and the value is the value that
that state takes if you don't pass in
anything what you get is the marginal
probability of each one of these nodes
given no evidence mostly to make sense
that if you come in and you know nothing
then maybe ten percent of people who
come in with unknown conditions with
unknown conditions or actually pregnant
and you're most like the symptom is
bloating compared to the others now you
can let's say that we have a patient who
says that they are suffering from
bloating low energy but they are not
suffering from loss of appetite vomiting
or abdominal cramps if you feed this in
then what you see if what you see is
that if you care about these three
values the most you would say okay well
the probability of having ovarian cancer
has sought up in order to be safe I'm
going to pursue that further in order
tests for BRCA 2 and BRCA 1 when those
tests come back let's say that you test
negative for mutation in BRCA 1 but you
test positive for mutation in BRCA 2
this causes the probability of you
having ovarian cancer to skyrocket you
went from basically 16% to 92% and the
probability of these others is very low
because the symptoms that you have can
be explained by the fact that you would
have ovarian cancer rather than needing
some complex mess of all of them let's
say that another patient comes in and
the first thing they complain about is
that they're suffering from vomiting
bloating and low energy I know that this
is an exciting topic for all of you
talking about vomiting of patients what
we see most likely is that there's a 91%
chance of ovarian cancer and just a 20%
chance of pregnancy this so this is
actually a real-world example that I've
read about which is particularly
interesting to me in order to fill in
all of the symptoms the doctor said okay
well it seems like you have ovarian
cancer so I'm going to assume that you
have
loss of appetite and you don't have
abdominal cramps so he put that into the
network the network basically said yeah
so there's basically a 100% chance that
this person has ovarian cancer what
happened is that then a nurse came in
and wanted to check all these symptoms
and went through and all the patient
agreed with all of them except for loss
of appetite the person said that they
were suffering from cravings as well
which is very unusual for someone with
ovarian cancer and so if you plug that
in what happens is that not having a
loss of appetite still means that it's
likely of ovarian cancer but this
probability of you being pregnant also
jumps this person ended up both having
ovarian cancer and being [ __ ] dent which
was terrible but they were able to live
long enough to deliver the child because
of this diagnosed because of the nurse
actually asking the father questions so
a Bayesian network is extremely powerful
if you're able to use it correctly let's
talk about built-in parallels they said
pomegranate has this you're covered you
don't need to think about this you'll
need to implement your own things I
basically right now have simple wrappers
for these parallelization things but
it's only going to get better and more
intuitive to use the more time I have in
order to implement this let's say that
we implement a mixture of multivariate
Gaussian distributions as you would
expect with some you know vector of
means and some covariance matrix and you
have some data if you want to predict
then you can either call the predict
method and that won't work as normal or
you can use this predict functional
wrapper will you pass in the classifier
the data and the number of jobs you want
to use it makes sense that the number of
jobs you goes want and predict basically
give you the same thing
because underlying that's what exactly
happens but if you increase the number
of jobs then you get faster prediction
the more data you feed in be more
efficient this parallel processing is it
has a lot of it can have a lot of
overhead at the beginning but if you
have gigantic datasets then you're gonna
get basically a linear improvement but
by using multi-threading here I was
doing a small example because I wanted
to make sure it finished in time for me
to give this talk today this is in
contrast to other libraries which many
many of them may implement parallel
processing for model
but almost none of them implement
parallel processing for the predict
prediction or predicting the
probabilities using these models now
let's compare just to make sure that I'm
not cheating somehow we compare all of
the predictions made by using the
predict method to all the predictions
made using n jobs equals four and we see
that we basically get a complete match
but there are there are 25 possible
there are 25 possible classes and each
example it gets the same result as you
would expect and it orders them properly
for you without you having to think
about what the ordering after
parallelization would be you don't use
naive bayes you can pass the same
distributions that you made your mixture
model with into the naive Bayes
classifier let's say you want to predict
probability predict the probability in
parallel you see a you see a pretty big
speed improvement if you use number of
jobs equals 4 compared to just going at
it by itself and there is literally no
difference in the quality calculations
that it returns which is which is cut
which is really good given that
returning double it's not integers so
with my remaining 15 minutes I think I'd
like to talk about
I like the basically get into the finale
and the finale is going to mirror the
research that I was doing as an
undergraduate and it's going to tie in
many of the concepts which I've
introduced to you about pomegranates so
far basically my research was about
identifying epigenetic modifications of
cytosine these are small modifications
the underlying DNA sequence which can
turn on which can turn genes on or off
this makes sense because every cell
every cell in your body contains the
full copy of the human genome but you
have a variety of different cells how do
you have different cells that they all
have the same instruction is said one of
the reasons is through DNA methylation
where you turn off genes that aren't
related to the functional tasks you want
this soured of pateros unfortunately
right now when you try to sequence DNA
it's a pretty complex method in order to
get this epigenetic landscape you have
to first sequence the DNA then you have
to do some like crazy chemical
modifications on it they have to bathe
it in some sort of crazy chemicals and
then sequence it again and compare the
two sequences and then you can infer it
and there's actually no published
innovate for how
good this is so you kind of have to
trust that it's just working we were
hoping that the nanopore in addition to
distinguishing the four canonical
nucleotides from each other could also
distinguish these different epigenetic
states of cytosine from each other so
what we did is that we created template
molecules which will identical in every
position except for one and this in this
one position it boy either a cytosine a
methyl cytosine or a hydroxymethyl
cytosine basically this would end up
influencing eight positions flanking
eight persons including these three
positions that are indicated in red what
you would see or the age six would look
like this for the different
modifications that for cytosine you'd
have some pattern for methyl cytosine it
looks like you had some states were to
around the same in some states which had
a some states which were had a higher
amplitude with compared to hydroxymethyl
cytosine it seems like he might have a
higher beginning but a lower core here
when it was passing through the nanowire
so what we did is we created a
modification of something called a
global sequence alignment hidden Markov
model what this does is basically a
repeating structure of these three
states a silent state representing a
delete basically they don't quite line
up a uniform distribution map using an
insert again representing they don't
quite line up and in a different way and
then a Matt's saying that at this
position I went to see an A so if you
wanted to model exactly the sequence C
80 you would put in the new you'd put in
C here a here and T here each column
corresponds to one position in the
profile that you would like to model we
knew what was going on in the underlying
sequence here because we had the
underlying sequence so we were able to
create a model width so what we'd like
to do is create three separate models
one model for cytosine one for methyl
cytosine and one for hydroxymethyl site
is in ultimately this is going to be a
mixture of models just like we had a
mixture of different samples in the
experimental apparatus however what we
would also like to do is tie together
some of these states not just within the
same model but across different models
in this case the insert distribution we
wanted it to be something which was
based
like a uniform distribution or something
non informative but we didn't want
different insert probabilities at
different positions in the profile
because we didn't have Davis to support
that and we didn't want different insert
probabilities in different models
because that doesn't make sense either
they're all modeling the same phenomenon
but also we knew that our sequences had
some beginning which was identical for
all of the sequences and some ending
that was identical for all of those
sequences as well it was only in the
middle that they were different and so
what he wanted is to tie the beginning
distributions for this model across all
three of the models and we're going to
tie the end distributions as well only
allowing the middle distributions to
vary in pomegranate you can probably see
how this type of thing is intuitive you
create the distribution objects that
correspond to all these positions you'd
like to see then you just pass literally
the same distribution object into
different models
this means that they're tied not just
within the model but across these
different models because they're
literally the same object we then create
the three models model C Methot C and
hydroxymethyl site is in and we pass
them into a general mixture model as
we've done in the past if we create a
random sequence from the first one the
second one in the third one and do
predict probability we get results that
we would expect that the sequence
generated from the first hidden markov
model is most likely to have come from
it the middle one from the middle and
the last one from the last now this is
basically the grand finale of the things
that you can do in pomegranate so I'm
gonna compare the time that it takes to
fit this model to around 1,000 sequences
that were generated from it
unfortunately I don't have the actual
data anymore I forgot to give myself
access to that when I left the
University of California Santa Cruz so I
had to basically make synthetic data for
expediency for this talk so we have a
thousand samples that a randomly
generated from the components of this
distribution and we'd like to fit it but
we don't want to just fit it because in
my vo case with Mars which is slightly
big not slightly bigger but much bigger
and much more data that would take it
would take several hours in order to fit
we want to compare fitting normally to
fitting using one of these
parallelization wrappers and what we see
is that we get a major speed improvement
basically the first tube take all three
of them give you the same total
improvement which is the total
improvement over the course of the bomb
Wells expectation maximization algorithm
it means that giving you the exact same
result but we're seeing that it takes
around 92 to 96 seconds to do it with
one thread but 29 seconds to do it with
four threads the basically means that
we're getting is three times speed
improvement using three threads on this
on this kind of hacky thing that not
happy thing this um this simple
parallelization mapa
the simple paralyzation wrapper that I
wrote I don't have a slide to show it
but I have one hidden Markov models with
48 threads on my research computer and
you get pretty much a Nia you get pretty
much any linear improvement in the speed
based on that and to my knowledge not
only is there no package which supports
hidden Markov models to the same extent
the pomegranate does but none of them
support any type of parallelization so
go back to the main point that I want
you to leave here with pomegranate can
do more than other packages that use
similar things we can do it faster than
these other packages and it's very
intuitive to use also multi-threading
thank you for your time